cheaply this is Professor Mike Bradley
with his latest invention a pump feat
filtered air into a hood protecting the
wearer from covet 19 Mike thinks it
could be a lifesaver for doctors on the
front line and help workers at risk like
carers and bus drivers but how does a
man with an idea make that idea a
reality
it starts in his back garden workshop so
I'm professor Mike Bradley from the
University of Greenwich but you can
probably tell it I'm in my home workshop
at the moment because of course all our
university labs are locked up during the
lockdown so we've had to resort to using
some somewhat hand-to-mouth facilities
let me introduce you to my assistant
I call him Pepe because he's testing PPE
for us he's very patient but not very
good company on a night in so you can
see we've got the the clear plastic
bubble we've got the seal that goes
around the neck underneath which is tied
in tight in here because this has inside
it what we call positive pressure that
is to say we push air into here and the
air permeates out through the fabric at
the bottom that means that anywhere
where there is leakage it's of clean air
outwards so it's impossible for
contamination to get in so the positive
pressure gives us the positive
protection that enables us to work with
highly dangerous materials and also will
give that level of protection for
healthcare workers against viruses in
the air and suchlike what I'll do I'll
start the start the air pump so
requestor there the fan starts to run
and that is pumping air
through the chair you can see yeah this
is what we call an inclined manometer
and this gives us a measurement of the
air flow rate so where the water moves
up the sloped pipe the relative movement
of the water is a measurement of the air
flow as indicated through the venturi
meter here sugar is a particulate
material Mike is a professor with
particle technology that might mean
working out how flavored powder can
adhere evenly to crisps flavor burst or
it might mean working with nuclear dust
asbestos or lead and that's where his
expertise in PPE personal protective
equipment comes in some of these
materials you only need one particle and
it can seriously spoil your life much
much more dangerous than Corona so of
course we're used to wearing PPE that
has a very high level of integrity and
it's that high level of integrity in PPE
which of course our current healthcare
system is not providing our doctors and
nurses Mike has assembled a team that
includes a viral epidemiologist
anesthetist
engineers and a retired merchant banker
and Toyota have designed an assembly
line to produce the pumps at volume if
there is demand the aim is to get the
hoods into hospitals like this one
doctors in critical care staff here at
Louis Sherman Greenwich NHS Trust in
South London have been evaluating Mike's
prototype
alongside two other designs so there's a
minimum of noise inside because the fan
obviously generates a certain amount
always and without a silencer that this
to the perhaps are speaking to you
how easy is it to have verbal
communication
because that's something that we thank
that a particular challenge at working
with particularly being this wrong not
only when you've got a team working
together in a busy communication so if
you like to try it on dozens of doctors
nurses and healthcare workers have died
in the UK during the pandemic and some
victims families have blamed the lack of
adequate PPE when I first tried it I was
a bit concerned about was that the
optics through the plastic wouldn't be
good enough or like intubation or
something like that
each of Mike's pleasure hoods will cost
around three to five hundred pounds
depending on the number produced but he
believes the safety benefits will pay
off no gaps for contaminated air to get
through no pressure sores improved
comfort and communication for these
tests and ENT surgeons who are looking
down people's throats all day you will
very much exposed to whatever is in the
patient's airway and at the moment
that's coded montine there could be any
infective agent TV so we're just going
to simulate an intubation here just to
give us an idea but it looks like
and went on to the windpipe to blow the
cuff up on the tube and take the Stoke
out and and then we will be able to stop
sent over unobstructed view very easy
read you need something that's going to
keep you safe that whole tiny with the
patient the trust is now pretty much
hood forward for clinical trials
starting in operating theaters what
we're trying to do at the moment and
people like Mike helping is to get rapid
solutions to problems that haven't
really been properly thought through by
the hospitals but my government by you
know policy makers as well because we've
just not really experienced anything
like this before in the modern time so
we need rapid solutions to very very
serious problems and if manufacturers
and inventors can be mobilized more
quickly and flexibly with this approach
than a traditional approach then I'm all
for that
the outbreak has mobilized a new army of
manufacturers to fill the shortfall in
PPE schools charities and hobbyists have
put their 3d printers to use making
visors factories have switched from
shirts dresses and jeans to medical
gowns and masks Mike also look to an
unlikely source to help with his
prototypes he's a keen dancer and he
enlisted a local dressmaker to so hoods
collars and belts one is on these types
they're a bit too slippery and so of
course mobilizing all sorts of resources
that otherwise would not be would not be
used for this kind of thing is
advantageous because it enables us to
make use of parts of the economy that
are underemployed at the moment and at
the same time gives us the capacity that
we need to produce what we know the
wedding and I don't know how many weeks
Mike isn't the only one to have come up
with something like this they're a US
and Chinese designs and a team in South
Hampton has developed their own
respirator hood after testing in the
wards the University Hospital they're
placed an order for five thousand units
with the local manufacturer mike needs
to finalize the prototype before he
applies for regulatory approval under
the fast-track scheme that should take
around three weeks but it costs
thousands of pounds and once the
application is accepted he can't change
the design approval for use outside
healthcare could take several months he
says it's a frustrating procedure at the
moment the situation is to me seems
terribly risk-averse in as much as that
anything new is not allowed to be you
because there may be a risk it may not
perform but how does that stack up
against the well-known risk that we have
of so many people dying because they're
getting sick with no vaccine guaranteed
and governments around the world keen to
get their economies back to work
masks have already become the norm hoods
like this could be next
[Music]